[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public et merci
de votre fidélité vous êtes de plus en
plus nombreux à nous suivre sur Public
Sénat et ça nous conforte dans notre
choix de prendre du recul sur
l'actualité de donner du temps à nos
experts pour donner du sens aux crises
que nous traversons voici le sommaire de
ce 14 novembre déjà deux mois de
contestation en Iran à une mobilisation
qui ne faiblit pas une révolution qui
peut faire tomber le régime des Molas
quel rôle peuvent jouer les pays
occidentaux et notamment la diplomatie
française faut-il renforcer les
sanctions contre le pays ce sera notre
débat d'actu et puis dans trois quarts
d'heure notre second débat vous savez
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour il portera sur les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique sur notre santé
ce chiffre nous a alerté 58% de maladies
infectieuses susceptibles de s'aggraver
à cause du climat allons nous voir
apparaître de nouvelles pathologies
Moscou les humains les animaux les
végétaux peuvent-ils s'adapter au
changement climatiques réponse tout à
l'heure mais d'abord le président de la
République qui s'affiche en première
ligne dans le dossier iranien Emmanuel
Macron a reçu quatre militants de la
liberté c'était en vendredi en marge du
forum pour la paix entre tiens diffusé
ce matin sur France Inter retour sur ce
rendez-vous et sur deux mois de
contestation avec Fabien avec Air une
photo devenue virale royapy Rahi 25 ans
la tête rasée se tient debout sur la
tombe de sa mère tu es lors d'une
manifestation le 20 septembre dernier en
Iran
ils ont tué ma mère
à bout portant alors qu'elle ne faisait
que participer à une manifestation
pacifique
la jeune femme réfugie en France a été
reçue avec trois autres militants
iraniennes vendredi à l'Élysée une
rencontre à l'issue de laquelle Emmanuel
Macron s'est déclaré favorable à des
sanctions cibles et contre le régime
démolas car depuis bientôt deux mois les
manifestations ne faiblissent pas en
Iran déclenché par la mort en détention
le 16 septembre dernier de Macha Amini
une Iranienne de 22 ans arrêtée par la
police des mœurs pour infraction au code
vestimentaire des femmes en Iran depuis
les mêmes scènes se répètent à travers
les grandes villes du pays des femmes
enlèvent leur foulard acclamé par la
foule et des manifestants scandent des
slogans contre la République islamique
comme ici à zaedan dans le sud-est du
pays les revendications dépassent
désormais la question des droits des
femmes et appelle à la fin du régime des
molards mais le mouvement subit une
répression féroce début novembre dans la
même ville de zaedan des manifestants
essuie des tirs à balles réelles
[Musique]
selon une ONG iranienne basée en Norvège
au moins 326 personnes dont 43 enfants
et 25 femmes ont été tuées par les
forces de sécurité depuis le début des
manifestations dimanche pour la première
fois un tribunal de Téhéran a condamné à
mort une personne accusée d'avoir
participé aux manifestations que le
régime iranien qualifie des meute
je vous présente tout de suite les
invités mes experts pour ce premier
débat madame mustaphavi bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directrice adjointe
de la rédaction de L'Express Bernard
Hourcade bonsoir et bienvenue à vous
aussi géographe spécialiste de l'Iran
directeur de recherche et mérite au CNRS
de les diriger la revue de documentation
photographiques Iran paradoxe d'une
nation parue aux éditions du CNRS
c'était l'an dernier Thierry Coville
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
chercheur à l'Iris l'Institut des
relations internationales et
stratégiques spécialistes de l'Iran et
j'accueille claire Chartier bonsoir
claire de l'habitude d'être aux autres
places sur ce plateau je suis très
heureux de vous accueillir dans ce rôle
d'éditorialiste politique bienvenue à
vous ce chiffre pour commencer qui est
le chiffre le plus communément donné
depuis quelques jours sur la répression
et le nombre de morts en Iran 326
personnes dont 43 enfants tués depuis le
16 septembre
comment ces chiffres sont-ils obtenus
amdah mostafavi et ce qui sont
sous-évalués est-ce qu'on peut déjà
répondre à cette question
je pense qu'il est probable qu'il soit
sous-évalué alors comment ils sont tenus
on sait qu'on a quand même des moyens de
communication avec l'Iran même si
l'Internet est coupé régulièrement il y
a enfin voilà on peut parler avec des
Iraniens quand même régulièrement au
téléphone et ils ont ce sont des ONG qui
normalement ont des relais assez
importants sur le terrain qui leur
permettent de d'établir un
comment dire un décompte après c'est un
des comptes évidemment il y a pas de en
ce moment il y a pas de journalistes en
Iran il y a voilà il y a nos amis
chercheurs ne sont pas non plus trop sur
le terrain donc c'est difficile d'avoir
vraiment un décompte exact ce qu'on sait
en tout cas est-ce qu'on peut voir c'est
que la répression elle est présente que
il y a pas de de discussion pour
l'instant entre les manifestants et le
régime qui a pris une position très
ferme de plus en plus ferme j'aurais
même tendance à dire par rapport au
début des manifestations où il y avait
quand même un peu l'idée de reconnaître
qu'il y avait peut-être une erreur dans
dans la gestion du de l'affaire Massa
Amini on est plus du tout là-dedans
maintenant on est vraiment dans une
fermeté affichée donc on peut on peut
craindre oui en effet que les chiffres
soient plus importants
Bernard Hourcade il y a eu est-ce qu'il
y a eu des révoltes équivalente depuis
depuis 1979 depuis la création de la
République système ça n'a pas arrêté
depuis le début il y a eu des
manifestations la révolution islamique a
été une révolution qui a donné la parole
aux gens alors les gens étaient très
divers au début des royalistes en
rupture avec le chat des communistes des
islamiques des libéraux des rien du tout
mais l'habitude de prendre la parole
cette institut instaurer un Iran et
désormais tout le monde a gardé la
parole surtout les femmes qui n'est pas
droit de parler dans le système
traditionnel même à l'époque du chat
c'était assez minoritaire et désormais
elles ont pris la parole
j'ai une pensée tout de suite pour Farid
bad el-krane notre collègue est en
prison qui a été la première analyser
justement les familles samisses et qui
sont ces femmes qui en chaleur noir sont
allés défiler dans les rues et qu'est-ce
que sont devenues et constatant
effectivement que ces fameux là qui
étaient sous le boisseau comment ont
d'une certaine façon pris la parole et
ils l'ont gardé tout en gardant le chat
de rester donc ça c'est complexe qui
font que aujourd'hui la les révoltes
sont là dans tous les milieux y compris
les milieux islamiques ce qui était
intéressant dans les manifestations que
l'on voit il y a des femmes qui enlèvent
des jeunes femmes qui arrivent leur
shadows on voit aussi des femmes avec
leur foulards qui manifestent contre
quelque chose de beaucoup plus grand que
la liberté avec ou sans voile et ça qui
est intéressant c'est que la
manifestation aujourd'hui c'est pas le
voile qui est le symbole très important
et au presseur c'est une manifestation
pour la parole pour la liberté que l'on
porte un tchado ou que l'on porte pas et
ça qui est intéressant et peut expliquer
le caractère on peut consensuel de la
manifestation Thierry Coville on a
parfois l'impression que les autorités
alors parliez durcissement de la
réaction des autorités qu'elles sont
peut-être dépassées est-ce qu'elles le
sont vraiment comment vous analysez la
réaction des autorités iraniennes je
pense qu'elles sont surprises
effectivement par l'ampleur des
manifestations je pense que c'est des je
voyais il y avait un responsable qui
disait que penser quelqu'un qui était un
interrogatoire voilà moi quelqu'un
on va dire un dur qu'il disait qu'il
comprenait pas les gens qu'il avait en
face de lui donc je trouve ça traduit
bien
ce désarroi c'est elles sont face à
manifestations je pense c'est la nature
est quand même très différente de ce
qu'elles ont vu aujourd'hui parce qu'il
y a une contestation quand même dans la
rue directe je suis d'accord et liberté
mais là c'est on veut pas de la réplique
islamique ce qu'on entend quand même
c'est mort ou dictateur c'est mort à
lire ramener donc c'est des
constellations directes je pense qu'ils
sont il y a pas de leader c'est
différent des manifestations qu'on a
connues en 2009 et sont elles sont
multiformes ou c'est dans les
universités d'un coup c'est des c'est
des slogans qui sont écrits sur les murs
je vais essayer dans les c'est sur les
autoroutes c'est du coup une femme qui
enlève son voile qui joue dans la rue de
la musique c'est les joueurs de avec
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux des
médias sociaux qui est important il y a
un soutien international qu'on n'a
jamais vu donc on va dire c'est c'est
vraiment des contestations directes
assez instance vraiment politique au
sens premier on conteste l'ordre
politique actuel et c'est multiformes
les joueurs et en plus il y a un soutien
quand même indirect majorité de la
société les joueurs de l'équipe diverse
de football national on voit de plus en
plus qui chante même plus l'hymne
national donc c'est pour une manière de
montrer leur solidarité donc je pense
qu'elles sont déstabilisées je pense
qu'ils sont ils ont adopté effectivement
la méthode dure comme ça vient d'être
dit mais je pense qu'il y a vraiment le
fait que savent pas trop comment s'y
prendre quoi alors la question à
laquelle on va tenter de répondre c'est
ce que est-ce que c'est une révolution
est-ce que ça peut aller jusqu'à une
chute du régime des des mots là alors à
cette question est-ce que c'est une
révolte et puis surtout est-ce qu'il y a
un éventuel soutien d'une majorité
d'iranien finalement au régime écoutez
ce que ce que disait ce matin sur France
Inter la militante Massy Aline et Jade
on l'écoute réaction comme toujours
spontané et engagé
ils ont le pétrole ils ont l'argent ils
ont des armes des balles pour tirer ils
ont le pouvoir qui peuvent raconter ces
histoires au monde occidental mais la
majorité pense que ce pouvoir est contre
notre dignité les gens y compris
lorsqu'ils sont à Eden peut se faire
tirer dessus la moitié de la population
ce sont des femmes on leur interdit
l'accès au stade les jeunes filles à
partir de l'âge de 7 ans ça ne porte pas
le foulard et non pas le droit d'aller à
l'école
est-ce possible que le monde occidental
gox ce genre de choses et pense que les
gens soutiennent un régime qui tue les
jeunes les enfants les jeunes filles
vous avez rencontré ma cyanis jade pour
pour L'Express ça fait plusieurs années
de longues années qu'elle milite contre
ce régime est-ce qu'elle voit une
différence au-delà de son militantisme
vous voyez ce que je veux dire est-ce
qu'elle voit une différence entre ce
qu'on vit là depuis deux mois est-ce que
elle a pu vivre ou accompagner dans ces
dernières décennies elle ça fait déjà
oui ça fait elle a lancé en 2014 son sa
page Facebook en fait voilà l'inciter
les femmes à se dévoiler en public il
faut bien se rendre compte que c'est un
tabou majeur en Iran c'est pas
anecdotique et c'est vrai qu'au début ça
suscitait des envies des voilà il y
avait des femmes qui postaient mais
c'était pas aussi massif que ce qu'on
peut imaginer ce qu'on peut voir
aujourd'hui ça n'a rien à voir et ça a
pris quand même une ampleur beaucoup
plus importante c'est vrai que c'est
difficile d'évaluer exactement combien
de personnes en Iran soutiennent ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'aujourd'hui d'Iran d'aujourd'hui
n'est pas l'Iran d'il y a 10 ou 20 ans
même la population est très très jeune
les gens qui sont dans la rue les
manifestants on voit que parmi les
personnes qui ont été tués il y a des
gens qui ont des jeunes femmes qui ont
16 ans des jeunes hommes qui ont 17 ans
voire 13 ans donc on est sur vraiment
une la fameuse génération Z la
génération TikTok la génération que vous
l'appelez comme vous voulez mais c'est
quand même c'est une génération moi je
les appelle les petits-enfants de la
Révolution islamique en fait ce sont
leurs grands-parents ou leurs parents
ils sont maintenant assez âgés qui se
trouvaient dans la révolution de 79 donc
c'est quand même toute une génération
même si qui est très qui est majoritaire
d'une certaine manière en Iran puisque
la population est très jeune donc on
peut quand même supposer que la part de
population qui soutient encore le régime
est un et plus faible même si évidemment
il y a des gens qui soutiennent le
régime il y a des gens qui font partie
aussi des milices qui répriment voilà il
y a tout un quand même toute une
économie et tout un système de personnes
qui qui ont besoin de la République
islamique donc qui vont aussi faire en
sorte qu'elle tienne alors justement
c'est révolte ou révolution c'est pas
facile de répondre à cette question
ce qui se passe en Iran vraiment très
exceptionnel et profond c'est sérieux
parce que c'est un peu la synthèse de
toutes les révoltes qu'il y a eu depuis
40 ans maintenant les ceux qui ont fait
la révolution qui ont fait tomber le
chat contre les Américains qui sont les
fils de roméni c'est le président actuel
par exemple 70 ans le président du
Parlement 70 ans ancien rôle de la
guerre ils ont fait la révolution de la
guerre tout cela ils sont pas toujours
d'accord en 2009 ils ont manifesté en
disant oui mon vote parce qu'il
préférait le Premier ministre de romeini
un monsieur Madinier jade mais c'était
une bagarre interne de politiciens ceux
qui ont fait la révolution étant du chat
la majorité des Iraniens ce ne sont pas
des jeunes l'Iran et le pays le plus
vieux du Moyen-Orient en moyenne d'âge
parce que les femmes iraniennes depuis
86 ont moins de moins d'enfants ils ont
moins d'enfants les Françaises
aujourd'hui dans les moines de 25 ans
sont peu nombreux en Iran par contre la
génération importante sur les 35 ans les
jeunes adultes qui sont diplômés qui
sont qui sont forts qui voudraient
travailler qui ont été en reparlera
assassinés par Trump qui a cassé la
console nucléaire ils ne l'ont plus ils
sont KO debout écrasés par la situation
économiques et ils n'ont pas soutenu
leur fille qui manifestent troisième
génération dans l'économie ils sont
manifestés plusieurs reprises mais bon
pas de maintenant leur fille et leur
fils se manifestent ils ont 20 ans donc
la troisième génération les arrières
petit-fils que les parents de la
génération qui manifestent les
soutiennent pas totalement
ma fille j'ai la maison à payer je suis
au chômage depuis trois ans mais bon je
suis d'accord avec toi c'est les mollah
je n'en veux plus mais concrètement je
ne vais pas risquer moi mon job et mon
salaire d'aller dans la rue je peux me
faire vider et qu'est-ce que tu vas
faire si je suis vidé donc la masse des
gens il y a eu des grèves ici et là
partout mais des grèves dans les milieux
du pétrole habitués aux grèves mais pas
une Megève massive la population et donc
la question importante c'est que la
troisième génération des arrières
petit-fils de Romain unique on peut en
plaisantant
ils font la synthèse parce que la
politique l'islam peut gérer l'économie
peut gérer la culture le voile ça c'est
le cœur même de l'Islam et donc ils sont
paniqués comme disait jérichoville parce
que faire de ces gens-là qui contestent
le cœur du système islamique et donc la
réponse n'est pas simple et là pour
l'instant c'est la répression c'est la
première réaction primitée
de des femmes est-ce qu'on peut dire ça
c'est compliqué c'est vrai que c'est la
première fois je pense quand même depuis
la révolution que les femmes ont un rôle
aussi offensifs parce que au début on a
vu elles sont elles sont là elles sont
devant et cries souvent il y a une sorte
de rôle de leader quoi je veux dire dans
un certain nombre de mouvements donc ça
on l'avait quand même jamais vu je crois
depuis la Révolution
je pense qu'il y a plusieurs dynamiques
ensemble il y a effectivement cette
dynamique les gens peut-être il faisait
pas attention à l'Iran mais bon c'est
nous ça fait quand même des années qu'on
dit que la société iranienne se
modernise parce qu'elle est de plus en
plus éduquée on a alors plus de 40% 4 %
de femmes dans les universités
on a je crois 6 à 7% des Iraniens qui
font des études supérieures contre une
moins de moins de 1% du temps du chat
donc on a une on a un taux
d'alphabétisation fortement augmenté
notamment de côté des femmes baisse du
taux de fécondité donc on a une société
de plus en plus moderne et on le voit
dans les enquêtes alors quand on peut
aller en Iran il y a la demande de
liberté individuelle depuis des années
et qui se traduit infinie les gens ils
disent mais moi je veux un état de droit
je veux un état qui fonctionne mieux
qu'il soit pas corrompu et puis je vais
la démocratie donc cette demande elle
existe le problème ce qui se passait
c'est que les gens il y avait
effectivement il y avait une sorte de je
sais pas comment l'appeler sagesse ou
maturité disait il votait jusqu'à
présent pour le plus modéré et je pense
que sur le plan politique il s'est passé
quelque chose d'important c'est que là
justement il y a quelque chose de cassé
ça je suis l'air tout ce qui est modéré
en Iran d'ailleurs dans les slogans ça
sort c'est je crois que l'un des slogans
c'est dur modéré pour nous l'histoire
est finie donc il y a un vide politique
en Iran cette société moderne et se
reconnaît plus il y a plus de réponse
politique et il y a un autre élément
effectivement alors là
je crois que c'est difficile à analyser
y a que c'est moi quand j'ai fait une
enquête en 2014 pour les entreprises
familiale et j'entendais effectivement
ah ben oui les jeunes maintenant ils
veulent tout tout de suite eux ils sont
pas prêts à souffrir comme on a souffert
donc effectivement ils sont là
cette modélisation de la mentalité ils
l'ont intégrée mais ils sont pas prêts à
attendre donc économiquement ces bouché
donc là ils sont dans la rue
effectivement ils sont beaucoup plus
radicaux que leurs parents leurs
grands-parents les jeunes ils veulent
tout de suite ils sont pas prêt à
souffrir comme comme nous on a suffi on
peut l'entendre aussi très bien
ne sont pas tellement différents des
jeunes moi j'avoue je suis assez bé
aussi un sur l'histoire et et la réalité
actuelle de ce pays c'est ce que je
découvre en effet très éduqué une
génération très connectée qui est voilà
qui est sur les réseaux sociaux depuis
longtemps donc ils sont pas très
différents
comment on peut qualifier ce ce
mouvement ils sont ils sont dans peur je
reste avec vous euh
madame safari parce que c'est dans tout
le pays aujourd'hui ou alors il y a
c'est c'est dans certaines grandes
villes et finalement il faut se méfier
de des loupe que qu'on peut avoir via
les médias ou les médias sociaux alors
ce qui est différent moi je trouve par
rapport à d'autres d'autres révoltes
bon moi je vous l'ai dit je suis
d'origine kurde donc je connais assez
bien le Kurdistan et souvent jusqu'ici
bon voilà ben quand les clients se
révoltaient bon c'était un peu leurs
problèmes pareil quand les balouches se
révoltent et un peu leurs problèmes
quand les voilà on a eu plusieurs comme
ça révolte et à chaque fois c'était un
peu le problème de de chaque petite
minorité aujourd'hui il y a quand même
cette unité qui est beaucoup plus forte
et du coup ça se répartition
géographique qui est assez différente de
de ce que l'on a pu constater jusqu'ici
après c'est difficile de vous dire dans
chaque village dans chaque campagne
exemples mais en tout cas j'ai
l'impression que il y a beaucoup plus de
présence géographique et de aussi des
générations un peu différentes on a
parlé beaucoup des jeunes mais ils sont
ils sont quand même pas tout seuls les
jeunes il y a aussi les classes sociales
on est on avait beaucoup dit aussi que
c'était plutôt les classes sociales
supérieures avant qu'il manifestaient là
on a vu des ouvriers qui faisaient grève
et donc c'est plus plus large dans la
société que on a pu voir auparavant de
ce qu'on voit d'ici évidemment on va
parler de diplomatie et notamment du
rôle de la France dans un court instant
avec avec Claire Chartier mais sur
toujours l'ampleur du mois et puis alors
moi ce que je retiens quand même de ce
que vous dites c'est que finalement
alors c'est logique c'est le produit
l'histoire du pays ce qu'on est en train
de vie mais ce sont aussi les valeurs de
cette révolution qui s'exprime d'une
certaine façon dans le le mouvement
qu'on est en train de d'analyser quoi
c'est tout à fait c'est ça qui est
étonnant devis de république islamique
c'est indépendance liberté République en
signe islamique et certains disent bon
les trois premiers de dernier mot est
important les trois premiers mots
indépendance liberté République je signe
où est où sont les valeurs pour
lesquelles moi vieux de 75 ans j'ai
battu veux-tu contre le chat la
République islamique machin République
islamique ne me rend pas vraiment pas
l'ascenseur
qui était les valeurs originelles petit
à petit elles se sont elles ont été
gommées sont estomper ou alors elles ont
été tellement digérées que le régime à
garder que islamique les gens ont gardé
indépendance et faire tes République
donc on a un décalage qui est de plus en
plus
tu as fait la révolution d'accord merci
j'intègre tes dynamiques alors il faut
pas ensuite petit détail je fais la
géographie j'essaie de voir où se passe
les choses et effectivement comme vous
le disiez un élément important c'est que
ces questions de liberté ça touche
autant des cures des ballots dès lors
etc mais le cœur du système n'est pas
forcément touché autant qu'avant bon il
faut être un peu nuancé dans les
manifestations que l'on voit c'est
souvent dans les petites villes à karaje
la banlieue de terre en gorge des petits
patelins ou sa manifeste plus c'est
cette classe moyenne c'est pas la
bourgeoisie occidentalisée qui est dans
ce plan qui ne attend que ça vienne ce
ne sont pas les masses populaires c'est
ces classes moyennes qui dit bon je vais
j'ai pas de piston il faut que j'avance
mais soyons prudent parce que on ne sait
pas ce qui se passe en dira en détail et
on est toujours prudent claire Chartier
j'avais une question c'est que
effectivement nous n'en sommes pas à la
première révolution
mobilisation forte et jusque là à chaque
fois finalement l'appareil répressif à
extrêmement étouffé comme il fallait en
toute la comme il l'entendait toute
cette contestation dans quelle mesure là
il est encore capable de le faire ils
ont le président Haïti dans sa grande
sagesse a réformé la police en mode
décembre dernier coordonnant la police
nationale et le gardien de la révolution
qui sont maintenant organisés de façon
beaucoup plus efficace il prévoyait des
problèmes la répression peut toujours
être mis en place mais ce qui est
important aujourd'hui c'est qu'un face à
un mouvement à la fois de fortes
contestations mais de basse intensité
basse intensité c'est-à-dire c'est pas
un million de personnes dans la rue
c'est 10000 manifestations de 200
personnes partout et ça c'est un
contrôlable vous pouvez pas arrêter ça
ça n'arrête pas ça le feu c'est un ici
il faut partir ailleurs et la police est
débordée par ça mais un mouvement de
forte intensité parce que c'est spontané
les gens ont intégrer cela et ils sont
en même temps et qui manifestent défis
de 20 ans même un flic pur et dur il y a
des tueurs comme partout le flic de base
du quartier qui doit manifester et taper
sur la fille de mon voisin c'est ma
fille qui est devant il y a un petit
problème comme cela qui se pose à
l'intérieur même de la police alors
c'est pas dire ça c'est Angélique non
mais il faut voir que ce mouvement est
de forte intensité mais de basse intenté
ça peut durer très longtemps mais avec
il est à la fois je vous comprends plus
bien de fortes et de basse intensité
intensité c'est-à-dire la guerre en
Syrie si vous voulez c'est une guerre
dramatique mais c'est pas deux armées de
phase de 500 millions qui se mettent
face donc ça continue partout c'est
mille petits feux qui brûlent mais de
fortes intensité passer ancré dans la
population et vous l'arrêtez pas et donc
ça va durer longtemps
je suis d'accord mais là quand même le
régime et d'ailleurs ça lui est reproché
il faut connaître quand même peut-être
qu'on parle pas assez s'il y a une
presse modérée en Iran et je pense qu'il
c'est des gens là je suis pas là je suis
j'essaie d'analyser mais il faut saluer
leur courage parce que c'est aussi des
journalistes actuellement qui sont en
prison qu'on révélé l'affaire Massa mini
en révélant qu'elle était absolument pas
malade comme les ciel de le dire le
régime donc il y a une presse utilise
tous les jours ça écoutez ce que les
gens vous disent tous les jours tous les
jours il y a des gens qui disent donc il
y a effectivement il y a une demande il
y a actuellement et face ils sont quand
même dans une impasse je comprends ils
sont dans cette logique depuis le début
à chaque fois qu'il y a des
manifestations en Iran le guide arrive à
dise oui c'était les guider de l'Israël
des États-Unis il y a eu quand même un
gros rapport de service de renseignement
à la fois de mystérieux enseignements et
des passes d'un rencontre qu'on dit en
gros mais c'est un autre monde quoi ils
disent oui c'est manifestations sont
téléguidées par Israël Etats-Unis c'est
complètement à côté de la plaque donc il
y a un côté je dis il y a un peu un côté
impasse ils arrivent pas on en parle de
cet impasse politique ils arrivent pas à
formuler c'est vrai que c'est vraiment
un gros problème pour ces radicaux à
formuler une réponse politique alors on
voit des bribes de réponse à ça mais
pour l'instant ils arrivent pas alors on
ouvre un chapitre un peu plus
diplomatique dans dans ce débat on vous
l'avez vu dans le sujet d'ouverture et
même Macron a choisi de de communiquer
sur ce dossier Rania en recevant
plusieurs militants de cet vendredi
médiatisation donc ce matin sur France
Inter claire Chartier on peut dire qu'il
passe à l'offensive en quelque sorte on
peut dire que Emmanuel Macron a décidé
de défier les mots là il faut dire
qu'avec la répression féroce qui s'abat
sur les manifestants iraniens depuis le
début de l'insurrection citoyenne le
régime est devenu un fréquentable
Emmanuel Macron donne presque le détail
macabre de cette répression dans son
entretien de ce matin à France Inter
qui se passe depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines c'est plus de 10000 personnes
on dit à peu près 14000 prisonniers
politiques nouveaux c'est des centaines
de morts dont des enfants dont des
enfants dont des personnes âgées et donc
cette c'est aussi un niveau de violence
qui est et de répression qui est inédit
et donc il doit évidemment conduire à
une réaction de la communauté
internationale
l'Iran c'est aussi rangé très clairement
dans le camp des pays parias aux yeux
des Occidentaux en prêtant main forte à
la Russie sur le champ de bataille
ukrainien Téhéran à livrer des drones à
Moscou et serait même sur le point de
lui fournir des missiles conventionnels
quant à l'accord sur le nucléaire pour
lequel la France a déployé beaucoup
d'énergie dans l'espoir de le sauver et
bien Emmanuel Macron a maintenant
compris que dans cette conjoncture il
était bel et bien mort c'est ce qu'il
dit en parlant d'un accord très
fragilisé pour lequel il ne pense pas
que de nouvelles progressions puissent
être faites alors donc vous parlez d'un
rapport de force dans lequel le prix en
français s'engage est-ce que c'est pas
risqué on a 7 ressortissants français
qui sont emprisonnés à Téhéran oui il a
encore la France a fait preuve de
beaucoup de retenue on actionnant des
canaux de négociations directes et
indirects tout cela pour très peu de
résultats mais vous remarquerez que le
chef de l'État ne parle pas de couper le
fil du dialogue bien au contraire il
souligne comme à son la nécessité de
continuer à négocier on est là dans le
en même temps macronien appliqué aux
affaires internationales mais après tout
les Américains font la même chose avec
les Chinois et envoyer les messages de
fermeté tout en signifiant qu'on reste
ouvert c'est le Béaba de la diplomatie
alors cette rencontre dont on a vu
plusieurs images avec des dissidents
iraniennes et là aussi une portée
nationale Emmanuel Macron a offert son
soutien au nom de l'universalisme à la
française le combat qu'elle mène
est un combat qui pour nous je pense
pour un sens tout particulier c'est
celui de des valeurs qui sont notre
devise d'un universalisme de liberté
auquel nous croyons
se messianisme qui est notons le très
critiqué non seulement à l'extérieur de
nos frontières mais aussi à l'intérieur
par certains courants idéologiques et
bien s'agissant de l'Iran on ne peut pas
ne pas se souvenir de l'enthousiasme de
Michel Foucault lorsqu'il éclata la
révolution iranienne de 1978 le
philosophe se réjouissait de l'avènement
d'une spiritualité politique tout à son
exécration des systèmes de pouvoir
occidentaux alors on en est plus là
aujourd'hui heureusement en faisant très
clairement référence à l'universalisme
français Emmanuel Macron s'encre sans
aucune ambiguïté du côté de ceux qui
défendent l'égalité des sexes et la
liberté face à l'islamisme la rencontre
avec les militants iraniennes a
d'ailleurs été initié par l'infatigable
champion du monde libre Bernard Henri
Lévy il permet à Emmanuel Macron de se
rapprocher du flanc gauche de sa
majorité que l'on sait très sensible sur
la question de l'islamisme et assez
désarçonné par l'inflexion droitière de
la ligne macronienne et puis si l'on
pousse l'analyse elle vient aussi donner
satisfaction à une demande d'une partie
de l'opposition cette frange qui
pourrait être Macron compatible sur
certains textes en tout cas c'est ce qui
expert c'est ce qui se perd le
gouvernement il y a quelques jours
plusieurs élus du parti socialiste et
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts ont publié
une tribune pressant Emmanuel Macron de
hausser le ton contre le régime iranien
et visiblement ils ont été entendus
merci Clara beaucoup d'éléments et ça
lance cette partie du du débat notamment
je voudrais qu'on commence madame
mustaphavi sur les ressortissants
français arrêtés en Iran c'est quoi
c'est une sorte de monnaie d'échange
comment vous l'analysez ça moi j'appelle
ça depuis longtemps et je fais la seule
la stratégie des otages c'est c'est même
au fondement quelque part de la
République islamique puisque on sait
tous que l'un des actes fondateurs de la
République islamique c'est la prise
d'otage de l'ambassade américaine alors
même si maintenant c'est pas également
la même forme mais il y a énormément
de ressortissants notamment des
ressortissants ayant la double
nationalité qui ont été arrêtées sous
des prétextes
souvent fallacieux pour pour et on voit
d'ailleurs la Belgique vient de ratifier
en fait un
accord d'échange de prisonniers avec
l'Iran pour pouvoir faire libérer un de
ces ressortissants ce qui va faire
libérer aussi un ressortissant iranien
qui est détenu en Belgique donc on voit
de manière assez claire que c'est un jeu
diplomatique et que l'Iran a ce moyen de
pression sur les sur les pays
occidentaux qui l'utilisent on le sait
il y a plusieurs français détenus ils
ont on a eu on sait qu'ils sont 7
aujourd'hui voilà c'est aussi
concomitant au fait que Macron ait reçu
Emmanuel Macron est reçu les
ressortissantes iraniennes vendredi
après ils devaient faire un geste
pourquoi fort parce que la poignée de
main qu'il avait eu avec Ibrahim Racing
en marge de l'Assemblée générale de
l'ONU
quoi quatre cinq jours après la mort
ça avait été très très mal reçu quand
même par les Iraniens d'Iran et
d'ailleurs donc ce geste il y a un peu
contrebalancer donner aussi un gage et
puis diplomatiquement ça reste quand
même important parce qu'il est le
premier chef d'État à reconnaître un peu
l'existence de cette de cette révolution
un peu la même question pour l'un et
l'autre la marge de manœuvre de la
diplomatie française dans un dossier
comme celui-là et peut-être aussi ça se
rejoint avec ce que vous disiez et
l'analyse de Claire Chartier le sens de
cette communication de du président
français là oui le premier sens a été et
c'est important de reconnaître la
révolution culturelle qui a lieu en Iran
sur les femmes c'est universalisme c'est
un point très important dans le rapport
de force avec Téhéran il sent qu'il y en
a quelque chose d'irréversible et fort
soutenu par les Français deuxièmement
très macronien il continue à discussion
en disant justement on discute avec ses
ennemis qu'avec des adversaires donc ici
je vais serrer la main mais ensuite j'ai
discuté et nous sommes affrontés et
c'est un principe de la diplomatie
il faut retirer nos ambassadeurs de nous
dire il faut retirer tout le monde
résultat la répression pourrait se faire
en vase clos comme en Corée du Nord au
contraire tout le problème et qu'il y en
Iran un maximum de témoins en assurant
leur sécurité bien évidemment les
chercheurs nous sommes interdits de
séjour en Iran j'étais invité récemment
à y retourner par une conférence j'ai
pas accepter l'invitation entre
guillemets le problème est que
aujourd'hui Macron au contraire dit je
discute et il faut discuter et c'est là
sur le nucléaire il faut des revoir la
phrase de Macron sur le nucléaire etc le
nucléaire c'est le seul dossier
international sur la table avec l'Iran
russe américain chinois européen dans ce
dossier sur la table qui continue d'être
là les braises sont à peine oujoyantes
mais toujours là et c'est le seul
dossier qui existe le seul moyen de
pression sur l'Iran quand le président
Macron dit il y aura des sanctions
ciblées il va interdire deux généraux
tortionnaires de venir à la Côte d'Azur
c'est c'est un peu humide
je crois que le fait que Macron décide
de continuer la discussion pour
justement
le rapport de force qui aura pour de
force en recevant les manies
manifestants et ma grandit vont
qu'est-ce que tu en penses monsieur
reissi il faut désormais donner quelque
chose je ne peux pas qu'est-ce que tu
veux que je continue à y aller soutenir
n'importe comment ou bien bon la
discussion commence avec les rapports de
force donc vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse Thierry Coville c'est à dire que
c'est un c'est ce que c'est à la fois
une rencontre tout ça évidemment préparé
orchestré c'est logique à destination de
de l'opinion publique française
d'éventuelle alliés politiques mais
surtout à destination du pouvoir iranien
instaurer sous la difficulté c'est pas
nouveau avec l'Iran c'est que
il faut à la fois condamner un
gouvernement occidental avec toutes les
images qu'on a il est obligé condamner
donc ça c'est normal tu as d'autres
côtés la pire des solutions c'est isoler
l'Iran parce que là effectivement on
donnera le champ libre au plus dur la
population iranienne sera laissée toute
seule etc donc il faut la difficulté
avec les clients c'est trouver le bon
équilibre entre la condamnation montrer
qu'on a rapport de force mais il faut
continuer à avoir des canaux de
négociation comme vous parliez donc ça
c'est instauré un rapport de force je me
permets d'ajouter quand même que si on a
les durs actuellement en Iran expliquer
n'est pas justifié mais si on a les
dures en Iran qui considèrent les
Européens comme suiveur par rapport aux
Américains il y a peut-être un lien avec
la façon dont l'Europe disons les choses
comme elles sont ces comporter qu'entre
Trump est sorti de l'accord on a quand
même pas fait grand-chose là qu'on
défende les libertés c'est nos valeurs
nos valeurs aussi c'est quand même le
droit international cet accord était
validé par une résolution de Nations
Unies on peut dire ce qu'on veut
l'Europe n'a moi je pense n'a quasiment
rien fait pour maintenir cet accord en
vie donc quelque part les dur en Iran
ils ont il y a une fracture en Iran
est-ce que le monacité mais allez-y elle
est dur ils disent maintenant écoutez
les modérés vous avez essayé la
diplomatie regardez ce qui s'est passé
et c'est vrai que eux ça comme vous
disiez il connaît ça depuis longtemps
pour eux avec l'Occident la diplomatie
ça marche pas malheureusement ils ont
été renforcés dans cette croyance parce
qu'il s'est passé depuis 2018 et il
croit que effectivement tous les coups
sont permis et on a effectivement cette
ce que vous appelez on papine stratégie
des otages alors l'accord sur le
nucléaire aérien on y reviendra sera le
dernier chapitre de ce débat notamment
parce que ce que vous disiez l'espoir
qui avait pu germer dans une dans une
partie de la de la société civile
iranienne mais puisque vous parliez de
l'Europe vous propose d'accueillir tout
de suite Steve Jourdain bonsoir Steve
venez sur notre plateau journaliste
évidemment la rédaction de de Public
Sénat pour nous parler des sanctions
donc les ministres des Affaires
étrangères se réunissaient aujourd'hui à
Bruxelles de nouvelles sanctions contre
l'Iran de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit de
sanctionner de nouvelles personnalités
du régime iranien une trentaine de noms
ont été retenus par de l'Union
européenne une trentaine de nouvelles
personnalités alors qu'elle a mis
octobre l'Union européenne avait déjà
ajouté 11 personnes et quatre entités à
la liste des personnes sanctionnées
cette liste comporte une centaine
d'Iraniens au total très concrètement
ces personnes ont interdiction de
pénétrer sur le territoire de l'Union
Européenne et puis leurs avoir ont
également été gelés toutes ces sanctions
sont prises sur la base une violation
des droits de l'homme au micro de France
Inter Emmanuel Macron a expliqué la
position française écouter le
je suis en tout cas favorable à ce que
nous ayons une réaction diplomatique
forte et des sanctions sur les
personnalités du régime qui ont une
responsabilité dans ce qui se passe et
dans la répression de cette
révolutionner alors certains ne le sont
pas encore les en complète les listes il
y a un travail qui a été fait au niveau
européen avec des listes complémentaires
parce que le pays est sanctionné la
grande difficulté vous savez dans ces
cas-là c'est d'être sûr que les
sanctions ont une efficacité qu'elles ne
pèsent pas sur la population on y veille
toujours et d'être sûr que Vous
sanctionnez les bonnes personnes
c'est-à-dire celles et ceux qui sont au
cœur du système Emmanuel Macron qui dans
ce même entretien d'y réfléchir à aller
plus loin en matière de sanction il a
évoqué l'organisation d'une conférence
régionale à l'image de ce qui avait été
fait l'année dernière à Bagdad pour
mettre la pression sur l'Iran il a aussi
évoqué la mise en place d'un mécanisme
d'enquête au niveau de l'ONU pour
poursuivre les responsables des
répressions il en finit qu'il n'excluait
pas la désignation des Gardiens de la
Révolution comme organisation terroriste
c'est une mesure qui avait été décidée
par Donald Trump en 2019 alors d'autres
éventuels mesures coercitives alors que
on l'évoquait le pays est déjà l'un des
plus sanctionnés au monde depuis 1979 et
la révolution islamique l'Iran fait
l'objet de nombreuses sanctions
internationales difficiles d'en dresser
toute la liste mais les sanctions les
plus cyliques vise à empêcher l'Iran de
se doter de l'arme nucléaire à la suite
du retrait américain de l'accord sur le
nucléaire et de la violation iranien
violation iranienne de ce même accord le
pays fait aujourd'hui encore l'objet
d'un embargo sur les armes et le pétrole
mais aussi de restriction dans le
domaine financier les avoir de la banque
iranienne la banque centrale iranienne
notamment son gelées et puis certaines
personnalités du régime font aussi
l'objet de restriction en matière de
déplacement on voit Thomas beaucoup de
sanctions donc encore en vigueur
aujourd'hui contre le régime iranien
reste à savoir si ces sanctions sont ou
seront un jour efficaces merci beaucoup
Steve Jourdain justement Adam mustaphavi
est-ce qu'elles sont efficaces pour vous
ces sanctions
ça dépend ce qu'on définit comme
efficacité après ce qui est sûr c'est
que
elles sont à la fois il faut faire
quelque chose en effet pour pour
signifier qu'on n'est pas d'accord d'une
manière ou d'une autre après on s'est
quand même que les sanctions de ces
dernières années si les Iraniens étaient
si contents en 2015 quand l'accord a été
signé sur le nucléaire c'était parce que
justement les Iraniens je parle de la
population s'ils étaient s'il y a eu des
manifestations de joie dans les rues etc
c'est parce que enfin les sanctions
étaient levées et enfin on allait
pouvoir retrouver un peu de souffle un
peu de souffle économique et un peu de
d'ouverture sur le monde extérieur donc
ça reste toujours un moyen un peu mitigé
je trouve des sanctions qu'est-ce que
l'accord sur le nucléaire de 2015 fait
naître comme espoir racontez-nous l'Iran
et sous sanction totale vous pouvez pas
vendre une cacahuète à l'Iran ou le
racheter un stylo bille c'est impossible
l'Iran est totalement sois sanction et
tous les élites Iraniens sont
sanctionnés interdit de venir en France
ça c'est une chose le retrait en 2015
pour la première fois cette classe
moyenne iranienne des 35 ans bien formé
avait l'occasion enfin de pouvoir
travailler les étudiants diplômés
pouvant trouver un job et avoir un
salaire correct des entreprises
étrangères pouvaient
naïvement et de façon un peu stupide
quelquefois mais dans investissement et
espoir que non pendant 5 minutes mais en
4 5 6 ans les entreprises iraniennes et
français sont ensemble et japonaises
américaines ou autres et peu à peu il y
a des étrangers en Iran des familles
étrangères en Iran des femmes étrangères
en Iran et peu à peu le système est
obligé de tenir compte ces nouveaux
rapports un rapport de force sur le
terrain pas sur internet sur le et
malheureusement ceci était cassé en 2018
par Trump et les sanctions étaient
efficaces effectivement efficace en ce
sens que ça a permis à l'Iran de sortir
du nucléaire et de d'avoir une bombe
atomique et de relancer le programme
nucléaire merci Monsieur Trump qui a
permis à l'Iran d'avoir quasiment une
bombe atomique aujourd'hui merci
Monsieur Trump d'avoir pour parisiens
qui sont désespérés découragés ils
soutiennent même pu leur fille qui va
manifester et troisièmement merci
Monsieur Trump et sanctions et nouvelles
d'avoir mis au pouvoir les plus radicaux
qui savent efficacement manifeste
réprimer les manifestations et bloquer
tout le système dans les sanctions
jusqu'à maintenant on a tous depuis nos
autres universitaires ça fait 50 ans
qu'on dit regarder en Iran il y a une
société extraordinaire qui est un
dynamisme exceptionnelle et on vient de
démontrer avec les femmes maintenant
mais c'est enfin la conclusion de
quarantaine de travail on a montré cela
et le gouvernement se bloque en face et
donc il y a en Iran dynamique il faut
libérer libérant lire les Iraniens nous
leur imposons des sanctions c'est pas au
Mollat s'inquiétez pas les mots là les
plus riches ils détournent les sanctions
c'est le marché noir il s'enrichissent
de façon fantastique ils sont contre la
signature de nouvelle Accord parce que
pour l'instant c'est le paradis enfin le
marché noir si l'accord était signé il
faudrait donc renégocier avec la
l'entreprise française le monde ou autre
et donc la femme peut-être de directrice
de notre ruisse allemande serait une
femme il faut donc qu'elle porte le
voile et c'est le porte pas qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on met en prison bref on met
le pied dans la porte et dans les
sanctions ont montré que les
sont efficaces pour renforcer le
nucléaire iranien pour renforcer le
despotisme et pour en couvrir des
Iraniens réfléchissons un petit peu
quand même Thierry cowy vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure c'est dommage que
l'Europe est suivie Donald Trump à
l'époque alors on n'est pas là pour
faire de la politique fiction mais
on peut imaginer comment la société
iranienne aurait évolué s'il y a si
Donald Trump avait pas déchiré cet
accord et si personne n'avait voilà ne
l'avait empêché de le faire personne à
la réponse bien sûr effectivement bon
moi j'avais un peu travaillé dans mon
mémoire d'agir là-dessus c'est
effectivement là
il y avait un scénario qui s'engageait
qui pouvaient laisser espérer une
ouverture de l'économie iranienne en
termes d'investissement étrangers 2017
l'Iran reçoit 5 milliards de flux de 5
milliards de dollars de flux
d'investissement étrangers ce qui paraît
rien pour un pays comme la Turquie pour
l'Iran c'était carrément le plus gros
flux d'investissement étrangers depuis
la révolution donc il était en train de
se passer quelque chose
Rohani voulait ouvrir l'économie
iranienne au secteur privé il a pris
comme directeur de cabinet l'ancien
président de la Chambre de commerce donc
il y avait un centre de signaux
l'inflation en Iran avait quand même
pour la première fois depuis longtemps
passé en dessous de 10%. donc on va dire
quelqu'un dirait un centre de signaux
était vert on pouvait avoir une
ouverture de l'économie iranienne alors
ça il faut être très prudent je pense
que donner plus de force moi j'ai fait
une petite enquête sur le secteur privé
iranien c'est eux qui sont porteurs d'un
projet politique aussi on le voit bien
donc donner plus de force dans d'autres
pays on en parle aussi au secteur privé
c'était aussi une manière d'avoir une
économie politique avoir plus de pouvoir
une classe une partie de la société
iranienne qui veut l'ouverture politique
mais ça se fait graduellement ce serait
très graduellement et effectivement ce
qui s'est passé c'est que avec cette
crise économiques il faut quand même
parler 40% d'inflation depuis 2018 donc
dans quel état et n'importe quelle
société regardez en France avec 40%
d'inflation chaque année au moins 8
millions d'Iraniens 10% de population
qui sont passées de la classe moyenne
dans la pauvreté Rohani il a pu exister
en Iran il avait il avait pas été tout
son capital politique qui s'était battu
pour cet accord les gens et les gens
étaient moins chers en fin 2018 je
comprenais cette colère alors moi j'ai
il me disait mais tiens tu t'es trop pro
régime moi j'étais là disant mais il y a
des choses qu'on marchait on ira
regarder cette société modernisée les
gens étaient foudrages ce que tout leur
tout leurs espoirs d'une d'une
amélioration de la situation s'écroulait
on avait l'inflation qui accélérée donc
je pense qu'il y a une colère il y a eu
un vide politique les modérée ont
disparu politiquement malheureusement
une des conséquences de l'action Trump
c'est aussi de quelque part de renforcer
les radicaux en Iran et excusez-moi mais
il faut bien prendre conscience il est
sanctions ça renforce tous les pouvoirs
rentiers en Iran qui sont plutôt liés
aux radicaux eux savoir hein ceux qui
prennent de plein fouet les sanctions
c'est ce secteur privé c'est mauvais
entrepreneur Iraniens qui sont également
porteurs d'un projet politique il y a
quand même des images je reviens au
point de départ de notre de notre
discussion et notre débat sur le
l'ampleur du mouvement à Madame
mustaphavi il y a des images qu'on avait
enfin que moi j'avais l'impression
d'avoir jamais vu c'est à dire des
portraits du reménil le guide spirituel
qui ont été déchirés ou brûlés enfin
il y a ce sentiment que l'ampleur de la
colère et
est inédite il y a le sentiment qu'on a
un peu tellement de gestes symboliques
de points qui comme un point de
non-retour il y a des choses qu'on a
l'impression que que ce que les Iraniens
ne pourront plus accepter que
cette propagande d'État qui qui commence
dès le berceau et qui s'impose sur les
esprits et les cordes et des jeunes
enfants assez tôt finalement avec le
voile qui est porté à 9 ans pour les
petites filles donc c'est quand même
c'est vraiment
moi ce que je trouve quand même ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que après 43 ans de de
lavage de cerveau collectif il y a
encore ça il y a encore cette aspiration
à la démocratie et à la liberté donc
quelque part oui c'est quand même des
images impressionnantes et c'est quand
même quelque chose qui est là sans
pouvoir dire ce que ça va donner mais
c'est difficile de se dire que tout est
comme avant on a plutôt l'impression que
rien n'est comme avant évidemment et
c'est pour ça que il nous reste 3
minutes c'est la question de la suite
quoi c'est puisque rien n'est comme
avant il va bien falloir enfin si il
peut y avoir une répression encore plus
sanglante et puis voilà tout le monde
rentre dans le rang mais bon tout est
possible je vous disais c'est une forte
intensité c'est-à-dire ça va continuer
ce qui se passe c'est important c'est
une révolution culturelle importante
pour qu'elle soit durable c'est un peu
comme les 68 mais 68 en France c'est une
révolution culturelle c'est devenu
politique quand les ouvriers ont rejoint
les étudiants ça ne s'est pas passé en
Iran et dans tout la clé est de là
l'armée c'est une clé ou pas du tout
l'armée et pour l'instant ne dit rien
elle est là il ne faut pas envisager je
crois ce genre de choses il y a avant
d'autres scénarios que un coup d'État
militaire de l'armée contre le gardien
de la Révolution et faisons attention à
la cocotte-minute du nucléaire qui
continue de bouillir et qui pourrait
éclater parce que si ça se passe mal les
Israéliens qui sont toujours là doré
passer à une action militaire j'ai
jamais cru une action militaire
israélienne mais là s'il y a de plus de
contrôle si rien ne se passait le
nucléaire quand tiré de bouillir en
quelque sorte et israélien pourrait si
l'Iran se retire du traitement
prolifération agir ce qui provoquerait
quoi une inseine nationale encore et de
revendication des femmes iraniennes
risquerait de passer à la trappe encore
pour quelques années il y a un vrai
danger il faut prendre ce qui se passe
au sérieux le point de non-retour est à
terme aujourd'hui donc ça veut dire que
là il faut je crois qu'il y a une
fenêtre de négociation de nouveau sur
l'accord sur le nucléaire il faut la il
faut la saisir là dans dans ce contexte
vous diriez ça Thierry covid moi je
pense qu'il faut surtout pas oui je peux
la pire des solutions pour l'Iran d'en
parler c'est l'isolement la correction
nucléaire pour l'Iran c'est aussi par
exemple en 2015 c'était la première
accord diplomatique avec les États-Unis
donc moi je pense c'est la clé des
relations diront avec l'Occident donc le
fermer c'est vraiment prendre un risque
énorme d'isolement de la société
iranienne et on voit que ça pourrait
apporter faut être prudent des bénéfices
déjà quand même limiter l'inflation
baisser l'inflation avec l'Iran plus
exporter tout son pétrole ça ferait du
bien cette classe moyenne qu'on nous dit
par ailleurs qu'il faut défendre et je
pense qu'à terme je veux dire je pense
je suis pas d'accord avec l'expression
excusez-moi lavage de cerveau je pense
qu'il y a une révolution des mentalités
en Iran à cause de l'élévation du niveau
d'éducation et justement c'est fort
c'est puissant et c'est je vois pas
parce que pourquoi la situation
économique s'améliorait cette demande de
démocratie et de liberté individuelle
elle est forte environ elle va rester
donc pourquoi craindre d'une je veux
dire au contraire l'amélioration de la
situation économique renforcerait encore
ses demandes mais est-ce qu'il y a un
décalage on va terminer là-dessus de
plus en plus fort entre cette propagande
dont vous parlez et puis l'accès quand
même à l'information même si en ce
moment c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
parce que voilà le contrôle de
l'Internet mais ce qu'il y avait un
accès à l'information via les réseaux
sociaux les médias sociaux qui
permettaient de montrer le décalage
entre les deux parce qu'on voit c'est
par exemple par rapport aux sportives
qui se dévoile
par rapport aux confessions d'État en
fait quand les
le régime demande à quelqu'un de venir à
la télé et de dire non bah mon voile en
fait j'avais oublié de le mettre bon ça
c'est des discours qui sont toujours
fait mais ça n'a pas de déco parmi la
population parce que c'était en fait il
est là le décalage c'est entre
ce qui est présenté est-ce que les gens
ressentent il y a vraiment un décalage
important merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce à ce débat je
vais rappeler Bernard 4 cette revue
documentaire photographique Iran
paradoxe d'une nation publiée que vous
avez dirigé publié aux éditions du
CNRS merci encore d'avoir participé à ce
débat